déjà j'ai vu une vidéo d'un youtuber qui
s'est fait il y a quelques jours et en
fait c'est quand j'ai vu cette cette
vidéo je me suis dit mais en fait il y
avait des conversations des screen qui
ont été balancés et ça me disait quelque
chose c'est screen a parce que j'étais
vraiment petite ça date quand même le
moment où on s'était parlé et là je suis
parti sur je suis parti sur mon sur mon
facebook sur mon Messenger et j'ai
retrouvé tout ça en fait et je l'avais
eu aussi sur snap mais je l'ai je l'ai
plus ce snap là j'ai que récupérer les
messages sur Messenger et ensuite du
coup j'ai j'ai été contacté par Maggie
et j'ai été ajouté du coup dans un
groupe
qui s'appelle
une quinzaine de pays une quinzaine de
plaignantes en tout enfin il y a une
quinzaine de personnes dans le groupe il
y en a 30 en tout qui sont pas dans le
groupe mais que moi j'ai vu des
témoignages et il y en a cinq aussi je
crois qu'ils ont déposé plainte mais
mais ouais en une quinzaine dans le
groupe et franchement vous avez quel âge
aujourd'hui moi j'ai 21 ans et quand on
a commencé à se parler c'était moi qui
l'avais démarché j'avais 14 ans et on a
vraiment commencé à se parler à
s'envoyer des trucs mutuellement quand
j'en avais 15 alors justement alors donc
vous étiez fan de lui carrément
carrément fan absolu j'étais trop fan et
du coup j'étais trop contente qu'on
puisse se parler en fait
c'est vous qui vous l'avez contacté via
quoi via en fait je l'ai contacté via
facebook mon nom qui se produisait à
l'époque au Paname le bar là le petit
bar le Comédie Club
ils commençait à se produire et en fait
mon nom qui me disait voilà je le vois
ce mec et tout j'étais vraiment petite
vraiment et je lui disais mais waouh
t'as trop de la chance et tout
j'aimerais trop lui parler à ce mec et
tout et il m'a dit ok bah vas-y je vais
je vais est-ce que vous aimiez chez vous
aimez ces vidéos ça faisait marrer ou
faire regarder toutes ces vidéos
en famille donc c'est des vidéos sur mes
écrans avec mes parents avec mes potes
on le regardait tous donc voilà c'est un
peu c'est un peu chaud de voir ça
maintenant mais ouais c'est vrai qu'il
avait contacté
donc votre c'est votre rond qui vous met
en contact avec lui qui met en contact
avec lui qui me parle enfin qui parle de
moi du coup et qui lui dit voilà ça
ferait vraiment plaisir à ma nièce que
que tu lui envoies un petit message etc
voilà les fans de toi voilà les petites
coiffes jamais 14 ans j'avais pas la
même tête que maintenant quoi et du coup
bah il a il a répondu il a commencé à
venir me parler aujourd'hui
on parlait normalement et très vite
c'est rentré sur alors justement donc il
vous parle il vous dites qui vous dit
quoi il vous dit j'ai vu ton oncle voilà
j'ai dit en fait j'ai envoyé quelques
messages il m'a pas répondu pendant
longtemps et là je lui dis bon bah je
parle toute seule xD Et là il me dit
plus maintenant avec un smiley qui qui
cligne les yeux comme ça et je suis
[ __ ] trop bien et tout on commence à
parler
au début on parle normalement il me dit
bah tu viens d'où je dis bah je viens de
la Réunion il me dit ok cool et tout aH
ça c'est trop bien la Réunion et tout
montre c'est comment et je lui envoie
une photo de loin de moi je faisais une
randonnée avec mes parents il m'avait
pris en photo mais vraiment on voyait
pas beaucoup et direct sa réaction
instant c'était ah bah 95% de paysages
5% toi tu peux mieux faire genre direct
en fait c'est entre là dedans et après
vous l'avez envoyé une photo pas
maintenant c'est un peu plus tard mais
en tout j'ai dû lui envoyer
peut-être de les avoir mais franchement
vous lui disiez quoi vous vous aidez ces
vidéos que vous étiez fan de lui ouais
moi je disais que je l'aimais bien que
j'étais fan il le savait de toute
manière qu'on était toute fan de nuit il
a utilisé le même mode opérateur pour
tout le monde il a fait le même schéma
chez moi pour tout le monde
oui vous savez que j'étais avec j'étais
mineur bien sûr et ça se voyait quand
j'envoyais des photos de moi ça se
voyait que j'étais petite même à ma
manière de parler j'ai réécoutais des
vocaux ou je suis en train de parler ça
se voit que je suis toute petite donc
vous engagez la conversation pour vous
vous êtes dans un rêve vous dites je
parle à la star
exactement
la star que je kiffe voilà ouais c'est
ça en fait et donc là vous lui parlez
tous les jours à un moment franchement
on s'est parlé longtemps on s'est parlé
peut-être pas tous les jours mais on
s'est parlé de février à septembre
d'accord on s'est barré presque un an en
fait donc là vous parlez
régulièrement et
quand vous parlez vous dites que ça ça a
pris une autre tournure et vous disait
quoi comment ça a démarré alors ça cette
remarque sur la photo mais après comment
vous avez commencé vous avez un petit
ami un truc comme ça ou pas du tout non
même pas il me disait juste en fait moi
je faisais beaucoup de photos à l'époque
je faisais beaucoup de photos en maillot
de bain exetera j'en postais certaines
sur Facebook il me disait waouh ça c'est
pas mal tu peux pas m'en faire des
privés pour moi etc il était je sais pas
après si je peux vous lire par exemple
un exemple je peux vous dire que ce
serait peut-être plus précis
c'est votre responsabilité parce que
c'est vrai que on a pas trop le droit de
lire des SMS ou des des messages privés
mais en substance soit vous pouvez me
dire ok bah je peux juste vous dire par
exemple voilà il me rentrait dedans quoi
il était en mode voilà franchement tu es
vraiment mignonne et tout j'aimerais
bien qu'on se rencontre voilà je pense
que tu pourrais m'envoyer une petite
photo après m'en envoyer une pour me
mettre en confiance il me disait tu veux
que je te filme mon snap perso donc là
il m'a filé son snap Nono super secret
qu'elle a évoqué juste avant et du coup
et du coup voilà à quoi ça a commencé
comme ça et moi j'ai envoyé des trucs
franchement je te l'ai envoyé une
dizaine de photos et lui il a dû m'en
envoyer 8
envoyer des photos vous êtes dit voilà
c'est parce que
vous aviez pas énormément non plus
comparé pas envie de rompre la relation
d'amitié qui avait entre vous quoi c'est
ça en fait il me dit ça en mode ouais
mais tu as un moment je me rappelle il
m'a dit mais en fait tu as envie de me
dégoûter genre en mode tu m'envoies pas
un truc c'est que tu me dégoûtes et moi
je vais trop je veux trop qu'il me parle
vous disiez à vos copines disiez voilà
je parle à Norman en ce moment je suis
c'est ça c'est normal ouais c'est ça
c'est franchement
considérez quoi comme quoi comme un pote
à maman comme toujours dit mais tu veux
quoi tu veux qu'on soit pote et il me
dit mais comment tu veux que enfin tu
parles à un mec super charmant tu
envoies des photos s'il te plaît si tu
as envie qu'on soit pote tu es sérieuse
et moi j'ai envoyé des photos topless
moi je l'ai envoyé tout le temps il me
disait ouais un moment il m'envoie une
photo de lui torse nu et je lui envoie
une photo de lui il me dit toi pardon et
je lui dis mais il me dit tu triches moi
je suis torse nu et pas toi c'était tout
le temps ça en fait c'est rebondissait
tout le temps sur tout le temps sur moi
un moment qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi ça là ça ça
a pris une nouvelle tournure où là
c'était plus embêtant ce que vous en
avez parlé à vos parents non à vos amis
vos copines
quand est-ce qu'il y a eu un basculement
côté vous avez senti qu'à un moment ça
allait trop loin bah j'ai compris quand
ça parlait que ça en fait et que voilà
il me disait ouais tu veux venir à Paris
tu veux venir me voir etc moi j'étais
loin j'étais à la Réunion je disais bah
non enfin j'aimerais bien te voir mais
voilà c'est compliqué en fait je voyais
qu'il voulait que il voulait que me voir
et moi je dis mais en fait tu veux tu
veux que venir me voir pour pour faire
chier pas quoi avec moi enfin moi je
veux juste que on soit qu'on soit amis
en fait il me dit ouais et là tout de
suite maintenant tu seras avec moi tu
voudrais faire quoi et je lui dis bah je
sais pas des pâtes
et il me dit sexy et après j'ai envoyé
un gif en mode genre coeur genre je
prenais rien moi j'étais petite en fait
et là avec le recul je me dis mais en
fait c'est n'importe quoi vraiment
j'aimerais bien essayer de faire de la
prévention pour toutes les filles à
l'heure actuelle qui se font des haines
par des Célé ou quoi et qui où ils vont
utiliser de leur notoriété pour pouvoir
avoir ce qu'ils veulent d'elle parce que
c'est exactement ce qu'il a fait sur
toutes ces filles moi j'ai vu des
franchement ce groupe les audacieuses
j'ai vraiment envie des choses je peux
pas en parler de ce que j'ai vu parce
que c'est pas mes témoignages mais
vraiment c'est chaud c'est chaud vous en
avez
un moment est-ce que vous lui avez dit
voilà ça va trop loin moi je veux juste
être pote avec toi ou un truc non je
l'ai pas dit que ça allait trop loin il
m'a juste demandé tu veux que tu veux tu
veux quoi avec moi j'ai dit être pote et
il m'a fait comprendre que non et moi du
coup je suis rentrée dans le truc et
après j'ai continué à lui envoyer des
trucs qui m'envoyait des trucs aussi
tout le temps mais à un moment ça s'est
arrêté quand parce que vous saviez ça
s'est arrêté en septembre
2016 parce que en fait ben je voulais
pas le voir en fait j'étais en mode moi
je suis je l'ai vu moi quand il était en
spectacle mais me connaissait pas mais
personnellement non j'ai jamais eu de
contact avec lui donc vous avez pas
voulu le voir franchement après j'aurais
été sur Paris j'aurais vécu sur Paris
c'est sûr que j'y serai franchement
c'est juste la distance qui faisait le
truc en fait mais moi j'étais en mode je
m'en suis rendu compte grâce à la
distance en fait que c'était pas
possible mais c'est sûr et certain que
j'y serai allé
sur vu comment il me parlait vu comment
il était bien sûr puisqu'elle et après
plus de nouvelles mais après plus de
nouvelles non il m'a dit juste moi je
t'aime bien et après ça c'est fini comme
ça on sait plus jamais reparti et quand
est-ce que vous décidez de de sortir du
silence et de dire moi je mets quand
j'ai vu une vidéo d'un youtubeur
j'ai connu ça quoi ouais c'est ça en
fait et du coup j'ai commencé à
j'ai mis des trucs sur Instagram et j'ai
mis des captures d'écran sur Instagram
et du coup voilà après c'est parti comme
ça et j'en ai parlé et en fait j'ai
après moi personnellement j'ai pas
forcément peur de lui parce que moi il
s'est rien passé de il s'est rien passé
dans la dans la vraie vie en fait moi je
l'ai jamais vu ce mec en vrai c'était
que c'était des messages certes j'avais
14-15 ans c'est hyper grave mais je
pense que c'est plus simple pour moi
d'en parler en sachant que j'ai pas eu
de rapport physique directement avec lui
que d'autres filles qui auraient
peut-être quelque chose moi je m'avance
juste Gilles ça
couper pénalement il risque quoi sur des
strictement si c'est établi de la
corruption de mineur d'accord et là
c'est 50 prisons et 75000 € d'amende
corruption de mineur c'est imposer des
scènes des actes qui peuvent tousser à
adopter un comportement sexuel dégradant
sur un mineur voilà donc là c'est 5 ans
après évidemment ce que veulent savoir
les enquêteurs c'est s'il y a un schéma
récurrent c'est-à-dire s'il y a d'autres
jeunes femmes comme vous ils vont
sûrement vous entendre qui ont été
victimes du même schéma avec une sorte
d'emprise exercée puis de rejet voilà ça
c'est pour la corruption de mineurs et
après il y a le volet que les enquêteurs
veulent établir aussi y a-t-il eu encore
plus grave si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
c'est-à-dire des viols et là le viol
c'est 15 ans de prison même 20 ans parce
que la fait d'avoir fait connaissance
par internet ça a beaucoup de gens de le
savent pas et tu ne circonstance
aggravante voilà dans ces cas-là donc je
pense que vous avez déjà été entendu ou
pas moi j'ai pas été entendu encore mais
par contre j'ai vu du coup les grasses
groupes les audacieuses avec toutes les
filles j'ai lu les captures d'écran j'ai
vu ça du coup son schéma et son mode
d'opérateur effectivement c'était tout
le temps la même chose en fait c'était
juste il nous mettait en confiance il
nous envoyer des trucs il y a des photos
qui sont similaires et après il y en a
d'autres ou moi par exemple j'ai eu des
photos que certaines filles n'ont pas eu
mais c'était toujours la même chose il
utilisait toujours les mêmes après il
faisait toujours attention à cacher sa
tête pour voilà quand même faire
attention mais si je puis dire
aujourd'hui
j'ai pas envie que voilà que des j'ai
pas envie que d'autres filles
franchement tombent dans le panneau par
rapport à par rapport à des mecs connus
quoi c'est pas parce que ils ont
quelques millions sur Youtube ou sur
insta que il faut forcément tout leur
donner tout ce qu'ils veulent en fait
parce que c'est clairement ce qu'il a
fait avec nous tout franchement moi ça
me fait de la peine pour toutes ces
filles parce que il y en a vraiment des
trucs c'est un rêve aussi qui s'est
fondé vous êtes disent mon idole ça en
fait clairement franchement ce mec
c'était vraiment à l'époque où il était
en pleine apogée ont vraiment on était
fan on était fan fans de lui moi mes
potes elles allaient le voir en tournée
carrément et là maintenant on voit ça
beaucoup plus tard si on se dit à
n'importe quel moment en fait ça nous
rattrape nos erreurs quoi parce
c'est une erreur qui qui voit qui vous a
marqué pendant des années après que vous
êtes dit vous en avez repensé j'ai
repensé j'y repensé souvent ça me
faisait ça me faisait de la peine de
plus lui parler après comme je vous ai
dit moi j'ai pas eu de rapport physique
avec lui les photos que vous l'avez
envoyé vous avez regretté après vous y
pensez
je regrette parce que ce mec en fait il
aurait pas été youtubeur et je l'aurais
jamais envoyé parce que c'est pas
forcément mon style quoi je m'en foutais
c'est juste que voilà il profitait de sa
notoriété pour avoir ce qu'il voulait
Guillaume
collaboration avec lui aujourd'hui c'est
Youtube qui dit envisager des sanctions
parce qu'ils estiment que les faits qui
lui sont reprochés peuvent nuire à leur
image à l'image des youtubeurs et de la
communauté YouTube voilà Norman il faut
le rappeler c'est une énorme star il a
fait près de 3 milliards de vues sur
Youtube et ce qu'on sait pas aussi c'est
que c'est un homme d'affaires il est
millionnaire il a revendu les parts de
sa chaîne pour plus de 2 millions
d'euros et quelques années
vous vous la prenez Gilles oui alors ce
qui est important de dire peut-être
c'est de redonner une fois sa version
des faits quand même voilà lui il dit
globalement pas du tout mademoiselle
contre vous mais qu'il est victime
quasiment ça va choquer de
cyber-harcèlement c'est à dire qu'il
renverse totalement il dit ces jeunes
femmes noircelles je ne fais que donner
son point de vue c'est pas du tout voilà
ces jeunes femmes Marcel lors de sa
garde à vue il a pleuré il a réussi à
être assez convaincant pour le moment
c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas eu de
charges retenues contre lui c'est pour
l'instant aucune chance
il faut vraiment le dire en
confrontation quand même avec la jeune
québécoise et que pour l'instant les
cinq autres victimes sont en attente
d'être entendus
je dis simplement que pour le moment
l'enquête est continué qu'il n'y a pas
de chargement et il a tout à perdre ce
mec il a il a maintenant il a sa femme
son ses enfants il adapté sa fille il a
tout il a bien sûr qu'il a essayé de
minimiser l'effet parce que là il est il
vit sa baisse live quoi il va pas vite
tout perdre donc c'est normal après
franchement je trouve que c'est un petit
peu un petit peu abusé de dire que que
ça à faire en 2015 d'inventer autant de
conversations etc on était tellement
petite c'était le début des réseaux
sociaux voilà quoi moi j'avais une
journaliste qui c'était arrivé avec avec
Norman qui m'avait montré des échanges à
l'époque
juste pourquoi on peut dire un truc
pourquoi vous avez pas porter plainte
avant parce que vous avez pas souvent
comme maintenant
ça aurait rien fait
c'est là maintenant que je me dis ah
ouais en fait c'est chaud et de voir
autant de filles et de voir autant de
captures d'écran et de voir autant de
choses autant de preuves c'est ça en
fait qui qui m'a fait prendre conscience
et je me suis dit
cette jeune fille était abusée quoi en
quelque sorte c'est-à-dire que le Norman
en question il a un pouvoir énorme ici
les filles effectivement les jeunes
filles sont bouche bées devant lui et
lui il a mis le bras dans la confiture
c'est tout c'est ça l'image même si
physique comment il a pas grimpé dessus
il a
su possédé par le par Internet posséder
le cerveau des cheminées et de les
utiliser et de ce de certainement de
s'amuser à dire regarde c'est là je vais
la faire elle va me montrer ses nichons
tu vois
exactement voilà ça parce que Jean-Marie
là
il faut juste
pour minimiser tant qu'il y a pas de
chargement
il y a pas de charge retenu contre lui
et il est sorti de garde à vue en tout
cas cellema ça va vous aussi voilà
aujourd'hui c'est ça ça vous paye cette
affaire ou pas moi ça me pèse un petit
peu parce que j'ai du coup je suis dans
le groupe des filles et je vois des
choses en fait c'est surtout ça aussi
qui me rend triste parce que du coup je
vois je vois je vois des trucs que
j'aurais pas que j'aurais jamais pensé
voir dans ma vie en fait surtout par
rapport à ce mec que comme je vous ai
dit on adorait donc voilà ça me rend un
peu triste c'est un peu
on a un peu enfin on a un peu tous
bouleversé par rapport à ça parce que
par hasard c'est tombé sur lui mais
après il savait très bien qu'on était
toute mineure et ça ne l'a pas empêché
de nous parler quoi c'est juste ça aussi
que je trouve ça un petit peu abusé et
que il peut pas il peut pas dire qu'on a
tout menti c'est pas possible mais on
est trop en fait